Trascrizione: Francesca Milani
Revisore: Sara Pasini
Ciao, sono Emanuela Masia.
Sono una persona autistica e ho una
disabilità fisica invisibile.
Nel febbraio 2021 ho aperto un podcast
e l'ho chiamato fuori norma.
Mi è sembrato il modo migliore per
definire me stessa, ma anche l'occasione
per confrontarmi con altre persone che per
una o più delle loro caratteristiche,
si collocano al di fuori
della media statistica.
Perché questo è la norma, un dato
statistico, non esistono persone normali.
Si può parlare di norma solo in
riferimento alla distribuzione statistica
di una caratteristica.
E una caratteristica normale è
solo più comune, più diffusa.
Non necessariamente migliore,
più sana o più giusta.
E le mie caratteristiche fuori norma non
mi rendono automaticamente sbagliata o
peggiore degli altri.
E sono tante le persone che hanno
caratteristiche fuori della norma.
Io, per esempio. Io sono nata con una
caratteristica genetica considerata rara
e chiamata talassemia major.
In pratica il mio corpo non produce
emoglobina, che è quella sostanza
contenuta nei globuli rossi che trasporta
l'ossigeno ai tessuti.
Per questo motivo vivo grazie alle
trasfusioni di sangue
da quando ho un anno di età.
Ne approfitto in questa sede per
ringraziare i donatori di sangue.
E invito chi può e ancora non
lo è, a diventare donatore.
Grazie.
La talassemia è una disabilità fisica,
ma non solo è invisibile.
Non è mai stata sufficiente a spiegare la
mia differenza dalle altre persone.
Gli altri mi vedono così apparentemente
simile a loro che non possono fare
a meno che proiettare su di me, come se
fossi il loro specchio, la loro immagine.
E anche adesso che sono
autistica e lo so.
Avere una parola più per descriverla
ancora non è sufficiente a spiegare
questa differenza invisibile.
Pensavo che fosse questa la cosa difficile
perché non si vede.
Quello che non mi aspettavo, che mi sarei
trovata ad affrontare il problema di come
far convivere differenze
ed esigenze diverse.
Perché non so se vi siete accorti,
ma sembra che esista
una gerarchia delle disabilità.
Le condizioni più visibili sembrano
anche le più svantaggiose.
Insomma, più si vede e più sembra grave.
Se invece non si vede, siamo tutti pronti
a giudicare la legittimità delle esigenze
di una persona che è
così apparentemente simile a noi.
Ma recentemente mi è successa una cosa che
mi ha fatto mettere in discussione
il modo in cui siamo abituati ad usare noi
stessi come misura di ciò che è normale
e quindi anche per stabilire a chi
riservare un trattamento particolare
a seconda di quanto si mostra
diverso da noi.
In pratica è successo che la mia vicina
di casa ha deciso di installare
dei dissuasori per i piccioni, ha cioè
addobbato davanzale e terrazzo
con numero cospicuo di strisce di
materiale argenteo che riflettendo la luce
dovrebbero allontanare i piccioni.
Se non fosse che fanno anche molto,
molto rumore.
Un frastuono sventagliate metallico che
non si placa mai,
anche perché basta
una brezza per farli muovere.
E io abito al mare.
Non è la prima volta che qualcosa per
me è insopportabile e per gli altri no.
Ed è più difficile farsi capire
quando è qualcosa
che anche gli altri sentono,
che si accorgono che è fastidioso,
ma evidentemente non quanto lo è per me.
E per questo motivo mi sono sempre
sentita dire che sono viziata.
Una bambina e una ragazzina viziata.
Anche gli altri lo sentono, eppure non
fanno mica tutte queste storie.
E così che sono cresciuta pensando
che gli altri percepissero la realtà
come la percepisco io.
Solo che facessero finta
di non vedere, di non sentire
o a volte anche di capire.
Io pensavo ma se ci riescono gli altri,
ci riesco anch’io.
E così ho iniziato a ignorare
ciò che sentivo,
pensando che anche gli altri
facessero lo stesso.
Proprio perché ero così simile agli altri.
Loro erano il mio specchio.
Io in quello specchio mi riflettevo
e pensavo di vedere me stessa.
Mi sbagliavo.
Lo specchio rifletteva molte immagini
di cui nessuna era davvero mia.
Sono dovuti passare molti anni prima
che scoprissi di essere autistica.
Ho iniziato a sospettarlo
nella seconda fase della pandemia.
Avevo passato un terribile primo lock down
in una casa condivisa
con altri lavoratori studenti al primo
piano, con le sbarre alle finestre.
Quindi alla riapertura estiva io ho
cercato un posto lontano dal centro.
Ma tutto per me.
E quando mi sono trasferita in questa casa
mi sono resa conto che non ero
più in grado di fare le cose che avevo
sempre fatto, dal fare la spesa, cucinare,
dal fare le pulizie a scegliermi
che cosa mettermi addosso.
Tutto mi sembrava un'impresa impossibile.
Ma soprattutto la mia sensibilità
sensoriale aveva raggiunto
livelli a cui non ero abituata.
E così ho fatto quello
che farebbe chiunque.
Ho cercato su Google.
Ho cercato sensibilità sensoriale
e ho trovato persone autistiche
che raccontavano la loro esperienza
dall’interno.
Quella è stata la prima volta che mi
sono guardato in uno specchio.
Ho visto me stessa.
Chiaramente non mi sono fermata lì,
ho preso appunti e mi sono presentata
da un professionista a cui sottoporre
la mia ipotesi.
Ho affrontato il mio primo percorso
diagnostico e ho ottenuto
il riconoscimento della condizione
autistica.
Chiaramente nessuno era disposto a
credere che io fossi autistica.
Io ero ancora abituata a usare gli altri
per misurare la validità di me stessa.
E il massimo sarei Asperger ad
altissimo funzionamento.
Mi hanno detto.
Ma soprattutto: a me sembri normale.
E quindi ho affrontato un secondo
percorso di valutazione
in un secondo centro specializzato
con un altro metodo diagnostico.
Stesso risultato.
Spettro autistico livello uno.
Allora ho fatto un po di ricerche,
non su Google questa volta,
e ho scoperto un sacco
di cose interessanti.
Prima di tutto, ho scoperto che la
sindrome di Asperger non esiste.
Non è più nei manuali diagnostici
dal 2013.
Esistita per un breve periodo nella storia
per distinguere quelle persone
autistiche che non avessero disabilità
intellettiva e disturbo del linguaggio.
Ci si è resi presto conto che la realtà
è molto più complessa e più variegata
di così, che anche l’intelligenza, il QI
è un numero che cambia con l’età
a seconda delle circostanze.
E anche i metodi per misurarlo cambiano.
E quindi non esiste più.
Le etichette di funzionamento, invece,
non sono mai esistite.
Non c’è in  nessun manuale
alto funzionamento.
Era un modo che avevano gli educatori
per capirsi fra di loro sul fatto che
la persona autistica di cui si
occupavano sapeva fare dalle cose.
Poi cosa?
Per quanto tempo?
A quali condizioni?
A quale prezzo?
Per questo mica c’era un manuale
per stabilirlo.
Non si sa.
Al momento nei manuali diagnostici c'è
solo lo spettro autistico e tre livelli
che non sono il livello di autismo, ma il
grado di supporto di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Infatti cambia, può cambiare nel tempo
a seconda di come cambiano
le nostre capacità di fare fronte alle
sfide della vita, che cambiano
a seconda delle circostanze
e del contesto.
Lo spettro non è lineare,
da meno autistico a più autistico,
ma somiglia di più alla ruota dei colori.
Ogni persona autistica ha una combinazione
di sfumature del tutto unica.
Ho scoperto davvero tante cose, ma
soprattutto ho scoperto che gli altri
non percepiscono la realtà come
la percepisco io,
che anche se la mia vicina di casa
sente le strisce per i piccioni, a lei
non fanno male quanto fanno male a me.
Anche che non tutte le persone autistiche
farebbero male allo stesso modo.
Siamo tutti diversi,
cioè siamo esseri umani.
Insomma, per tornare alla guerra
dei piccioni,
ho affrontato l’argomento
con i suoi genitori.
Perché non vengono più tanto spesso,
ma con loro ho più confidenza.
Sono loro, infatti, che ho conosciuto
quando mi sono trasferita in questa casa
e allora avevo raccontato di questa
mia scoperta di essere autistica.
Sono venuti un giorno a vedere come avevo
finito di arredare
perché ancora non l’avevano vista.
E così la mia vicina di casa ha scoperto
in modo indiretto
che mi mancavano da montare
i mobili del bagno.
Non so se potete immaginare la mia
sorpresa quando si è offerta
di darmi una mano.
Ho pensato una cosa semplice
come togliere le strisce
io gliela chiedo, lei non la fa
perché i piccioni sono brutti e cattivi
e portano le malattie, ma si offre
di fare una cosa molto più complicata
che nessuno gli ha chiesto di fare.
Ma l'abbiamo appena detto.
Chi sono io per stabilire le priorità
delle altre persone?
Ho accettato.
E un sabato pomeriggio, mentre montavamo
i mobili del bagno, lei mi raccontava
la sua vita, le sue difficoltà,
le sue scelte.
Io avevo i tappi per le strisce.
E nonostante questo, ogni
volta che lei usava il trapano io correvo
nell’altra stanza con le mani
nelle orecchie.
E così questa differenza invisibile di cui
forse aveva sentito il nome, autismo,
ma di cui probabilmente non avevo mai
immaginato le reali implicazioni,
improvvisamente si è manifestata,
è diventata visibile.
E così, quando abbiamo preso confidenza
ne ho approfittato per farle una domanda.
Com’è che quando ci sono
delle esigenze contrastanti,
le persone vogliono per forza
avere ragione?
Pensano forse di non avere difficoltà,
di essere perfette?
E lei mi ha risposto che no,
che le persone pensano
che i proprimali siano i peggiori.
E che quindi le proprie esigenze
siano le più legittime.
Di nuovo la gerarchia.
Se la smettessimo di voler avere ragione,
se la smettessimo di utilizzare noi stessi
per misurare la validità
degli altri e gli altri per misurare
la validità di noi stessi?
Se la smettessimo di lasciarci trasportare
in questa modalità da social media?
Mi piace, non mi piace.
Pronti a cliccare.
Sono d’accordo, non sono d’accordo.
Per me non è vero.
Sta mentendo.
La realtà è più complessa di così.
Non devi rispettare le mie esigenze
perché io, poverino, io.
Una diagnosi.
Poverina, io sono fuori norma.
No, no.
Dobbiamo rispettare le nostre rispettive
esigenze, perché entrambi abbiamo bisogno
che le nostre esigenze vengano rispettate,
perché entrambi siamo esseri umani
con pari dignità e pari diritti.
Io ho fatto un sacco di ricerche per
sapere come potevamo fare a dissuadere
i piccioni, perché ho capito che per la
mia vicina di casa è importante.
E lei?
Dopo quel sabato pomeriggio
le ha tolte le malefiche strisce.
La mia domanda è a voi.
Voi cosa farete quando vi troverete in
confronto con qualcuno
che ha delle esigenze
diverse dalle vostre?
Cercherete chi ha ragione?
Quali sono le esigenze più legittime?
Oppure vi disporrete all’ascolto,
cercherete un modo di rispettare
le esigenze di entrambi?
Quando verrà il vostro turno,
come affronterete la vostra
guerra dei piccioni?
Grazie di essere venuti al mio Ted Talk.